now if because of pretty woman that's
how the whole
george costanza came out right that's
how you get so that is part of the
mythology that i've been told so somehow
gary marshall
they were looking for george gary
marshall
married to penny martin
brother penny marshall penny marshall
ex-wife of rob reiner rob reiner head of
castle rock
he says oh i heard this guy i saw a clip
from the movie he might be good you
should put him on tape that's what i've
heard is that somehow it played him and
that's how it kind of started so how did
you get this i mean i know you've
probably told the story a million times
but to get this audition because i want
to hear about the kind of the neil the
uh the uh what's his name woody allen
kind of thing and you put the glasses on
yeah yeah
yeah so
again my i lived in new york at the time
uh all this all the casting on seinfeld
was being done in la they had seen a
gazillion people i guess for george some
very famous who i think had been offered
the role and either turned it down or
they got next do you know any of them or
you don't say yeah no chris rock danny
devito
the guy one of the guys they really
liked for it and he i think he said no
was paul shaffer
wow
yeah so i mean they were kind of a
little all over the map and uh
somebody said you know we should put
some doctors on
we should get some new york actors into
the mix
so that meant calling a new york casting
director just saying look we'll send you
a couple of pages we're looking for a
sidekick you know a funny sidekick best
friend to jerry seinfeld
about this age you know
no real description just sort of a your
your standard
young youngish character actor and you
were like who the hell is jerry seinfeld
at this point you probably didn't really
know that i i was a fan of jerry
seinfeld you weren't performed many
times you know i i didn't know who the
hell larry david was i
so i was one of the ones uh i maybe
through this gary marshall connection
and they called and said put him on tape
and all i had was four pages from the
pilot script with no contacts and nobody
asked about it because the casting
director didn't know the project she was
just
being paid to put some people inside so
you quickly memorize them of course
memorizing no problem uh
but i went what do i do with what is
this thing so it to me it read like the
dialogue in a woody allen show
and i went
all right let's go with that so i
i didn't wear glasses at the time i went
out and got you know got
some frames
and
i not only did in new york a thick new
york accent
i literally was doing woody allen like
you know
the gestures and the
the that voice
that voice
yeah
jerry it's it's ridiculous since you
know i'm doing woody allen just
blatantly nobody would mistake him maybe
not a good woody allen but definitely a
guy trying to do what he helped wow
and i finished the tape and i went
i never i'll never say that again but
that you know
and a couple days later got a call i
think from larry um
said love everything you're doing you
know coming out we want to have you meet
jerry you'll read for the network
and i flew out and they said don't
change a thing except
not don't do the woody allen voice do
new york do the glasses do all that but
just don't do the woody allen voice
and i show up to read for the network
and there's one other person reading
that day now i don't know jerry seinfeld
but i do know
one thing and that is one of his best
friends in the world at least at the
time was the comedian larry miller who i
had been a pretty woman with
and that's the other guy reading that
day and i go well
this is the writings on the wall of
course he's going to use his buddy he
doesn't know me so so i went in to do
the ring and i was loose
i was loosey-goosey and i just had a
great time going i'm not gonna get yes
so just have fun
and i guess
we you know we just clicked and i i left
the audition got on a plane that night
came back to new york and by the time i
landed they went you got it so